hello everyone very good morning and
evening to one and all today truly
signifies the culmination of your hard
work in the Relentless pursuit of
knowledge the knowledge that will enable
a person to embrace opportunities and
take on challenges with a Clear Vision
and
purpose it gives me immense pleasure to
welcome you all to this online
convocation ceremony for the year 2023
hosted by simply learn in association
with yumas University I am Arun Rak
Krishnan program manager at simply learn
responsible for learner success once
again a big congratulations to each and
every one of you for the remarkable
achievements you have made in the past
months and I'm eagerly looking forward
to witnessing The Incredible Journey
that lie ahead for all of
you let's pause for a moment and reflect
on The Incredible Journey we have
embarked on together the most difficult
component of this journey is in my
opinion was a commitment to attending
eight of classes every weekend without
fail for a period of 4 to 6 months you
put in hundreds of hours of study time
through lvc classes which is live
virtual classes online self-learning
videos completing 20 plus exams and
projects taking quizzes and finally
implementing all your knowledge to
complete the Capstone project and gain
your final program
certificate it honestly requires a lot
of commitment and passion to achieve
this and I would like to take this
moment to upload and appreciate each and
every one of you for your efforts
congratulations I would also like to
thank your family and friends for their
continued support in making your success
story I would like to introduce our
guest of honor Professor Joseph bomo the
associate Provost for interdisciplinary
studies and professor of of English at
yumas Amherst he basts an illustrat
career and exceptional academic
credentials he holds leadership
positions including chair of English
Department and Associate dean of the
College of humanities and Fine Arts his
surveys extends Beyond Academia having
been a member of the yumas amers
foundation board and currently serving
as treasurer of the American Society for
18th century studies notably he is a
two-time japari champ and a prolific
author with two books and numerous
scholarly articles to his name his
remarkable achievements makes him a
distinguished guest for our convocation
ceremony Professor Joseph we are excited
to have you here at the ceremony today
could you please share a few words for
our
graduates uh excuse me the video is not
turning on I uh
uh uh let me check Professor just give
me a
minute in for the simply learn team this
is well U I'm also having the same issue
as Professor oh all
right Joseph uh Professor Joseph I think
you have the access now can you please
try again I'll try again let's
see ah there we are thank you
great all right
I'm delighted to be with you today to
recognize the achievements of this group
of Learners who are completing
post-graduate programs and boot camps in
project management lean6 Sigma and
design thinking and Innovation through a
partnership between simply learn in the
University of Massachusetts
ammer we're here to celebrate the
graduation of exceptional students and
to honor their unwavering dedication and
commitment today as you complete one
chapter and and begin another in your
life's journey we applaud your resolve
resilience and determined pursuit of
Excellence we hope this experience is
another step forward in lives and
careers filled with achievement
continuous upskilling and boundless
opportunities congratulations to
all UMass amorist was founded in
1863 as a land grant University
dedicated to teaching generating new
knowledge and applying it to the
betterment of societ iety our campus's
strategic plan stresses that our
institution is rooted in the idea that
any qualified individual regardless of
wealth or social status should have
access to high quality higher education
we draw from and support diverse
experiences and perspectives as an
essential strength of this learning
community and accept for ourselves and
instill in our students an ongoing
commitment to create a better more just
world this Mission extends Beyond
traditional undergraduate education to
lifelong learning through programs like
those you have just completed you've
taken a significant Step Beyond your
under undergraduate degree and for some
Beyond a graduate degree to invest in
yourselves and embark on a graduate
level program in a highly marketable and
skilled area of study many of you have
pursued this learning opportunity while
also working full-time time and juggling
all the challenges and joys that
accompany careers families and
children it was your first time learning
in an online environment and taking
advantage of the different modes of
delivery provided in these
programs whether whether that meant live
online sessions recorded sessions or a
range of online Resources with problems
tests and real world projects I applaud
your significant efforts and celebrate
your
achievement as you can consider your
next steps remember that you've already
demonstrated your success at graduate
level work you can complete any industry
certification associated with your pgp
but every day you can apply what you
have learned to your work and extend
your
contributions I hope you will look for
new opportunities for advancement with
your current employer or in new
locations the Roman philosopher senica
once observed that the reward of a thing
well done is to have done it that's true
enough but what you've accomplished
deserves to be celebrated and that's why
we're here today please accept my hearty
congratulations and best wishes for
continued happiness and success thank
you thank you so much uh Professor
Joseph I'm delighted to introduce our
sponsor for today our chief marketing
officer Dr villin will is a Rec driven
Market marketing executive with
extensive International experience and
proven track record in managing $100
million plus Global Marketing budgets he
has extensive experience in scaling
businesses and taking them to the next
level he has worked in marketing and
digital leadership roles with
organizations like Microsoft HP and
Expedia among others Dr Lynn is a PhD in
operations research and industrial
engineering and also a masters in
aerospace engineering from the
University of Texas at Austin he
currently resides in Seattle with his
wife and two daughters he has been a
huge influence in making the yumas
programs at simply learn a successful
one Dr villan I kindly request you to
speak a few words for our
graduates sure thank you thank you AR um
so again I'm having issue uh opening up
my okay I think um let's see not not
able to okay here we go thank you um so
um um I was asked to uh to give just a
very brief uh U overview of a couple
slides but before that first to all the
fellow Learners I did like to uh extend
my deep and hard War congrats to to you
on this achievement you have a big group
of us uh um and simply learn included
cheering out today as you receive your
recognitions and we are so honored to be
part of this special day I applaud you
for your dedications it's not easy to
juggle among personal commitments work
and study all at once take a moment and
Savor your reward and celebrate your uh
celebrate with your loved ones and
friends and please do uh do me a favor
um if you will be celebrating your
achievement on social media please
remember to tag uh UMass and simply
learn uh we love to see you um we love
to see your network celebrating your
achievement um
so I have a couple slides I uh I want to
present here uh and they are very
self-explanatory so I'll go through them
very quickly uh this slide actually
tells uh tells you about the uh the
makeup of this group today uh so we have
in total 394 uh Learners with us today
majority of them coming from project
management uh and uh 122 come from Lin
Six Sigma and then we also have 10
individuals from U designning uh
designing thinking and Innovations so
here's a quick makeup of the uh the
audience today and I think if there's a
one word to uh to describe this audience
to me is actually diversity and so room
if you can move on to the next page
uh so um as you can see right very very
Diversified group of people we have
today and aside from diversity I think
um I think how you can describe this
group is also highly educated and
experienced right so you see a lot of
folks actually have eight or more year
experiences working in the industry and
you know majority of us have a bachelor
or even master degree or even higher
degree uh within this group so it's a
very nice mix of group uh with very uh
very high diversities and also High
highly educated and experienced so what
I would suggest is everybody to uh to
you know maybe stay stay in touch with
that um you know your um you know your
peers and and and colleagues uh in this
group right so I think I think this is
one good way for you to build your
network with people that actually share
your same interest and uh uh and and
passion and also this is also way you
can actually stay a breast to uh to the
latest in uh uh in the discipline you
are in so highly encourage that you
continue to stay in touch with your uh
fellow students um finally I I hope uh
you know that your new learn skill and
uh will unlock even more doors to the
success you uh very well deserve um
congratulations
again thank you so so much uh will uh it
was a great insights on the C thank
you now is the time to celebrate your
success I will collectively honor each
and every one of you who has completed
the program we will recognize all the
Achievers in each category and names
will be announced according to the
program furthermore we have invited a
few of our graduates to share their
valuable experience with us as we
proceed further we apologize in advance
if we mispronounce on any names
also I would like to mention that if you
have missed out on any names please do
not worry you can reach out to us and we
will make sure to include you in the
upcoming convocation
ceremony the first set of graduates we
have is for the postgraduate program in
project management the graduates
are SRI suant Abhijit
CI Billy ganga Nancy Maybel rajasri
Rohit
sujit congratulations to
all Vera sna Sarang bismar deepti Hima
Nishant Vishal Nur anit congratulations
to
all benia bavana umak Kumar kirti
Muhammad nisara shivr vamy moan Victor
Rahul congratulations to all
Akim Akil Alexandra Fida Alexandra
Alison Emma Alexandria Andres Alexander
akash akash bodla Aaron aayushi abilash
abinav the anudan shurit anur an
congratulations to all ano Kumar Arana
ashini
aani aino Amber ice Aisha Murad mahes
Benjamin bianka bishwajit suganya Lamar
Brad Brian
Bruce husna Casey congratulations to all
Koli chandana Chandra Charles chitra
wandana Sara clodine Clyde kosia c Tracy
Daniel Darren Don Drew Deborah
Malika DHA Donnie duus congratulations
to all duckins
quet Eric ilot Michael Eric era Mohammad
F Sayad Fran Frank
Gabriela Gary alobi G shanka grishma
Gregory smuti Gan gusta congratulations
to
all hanuma Hadi adiya Mohammad Navid
hitashi Susanna p Michael Jackson
Jacqueline Jennifer Jenny Jared Joanna
Joanna tuon Kelly judge Juliet Julie
Justin Ken kamales congratulations to
all
Bixler Kenneth Kiana Abdul mujib Carlos
gurprit Kevin
klin Nishi Logan Lulu Lam Jason
rameswari YF Akash Mazin Manisha line
chandini MD Aslam congratulations to all
Megan Mano
Marvin Michael Morgan Humberto Williams
Olga m a munal Michael K mujahid Manoj
neten narmada natti rajnish Anova nikil
saish congratulations to
all nian Tay Norman nibras Neil Usama
Vijay pavi parag
Paras maharajan Paula pavil evina
pradipa pra Priyanka Priya David Rachel
rajes Aris congratulations to
all renen Ram prakash rakba Roberto Ross
Rebeca Richard rishik Rita
Ricky Sara sajiv sahil Selma vincon
samika sandip sandya Santi Toma Sasha
congratulations to
all Sammy arene Raj MD Shah sharat
sharat prakash Shashank chrisy Shelby
Stephanie
sham
saifa Jasmine Sammy Stephanie suale Su
Sunita karun Taylor congratulations to
all theodre Thomas Taylor Leon n Wen
Brenda Umar
bamit
Jennifer vij pranda Kumar Christina Wasa
Wati Paul nudi vinit Wades Braham pal
Singh congratulations to
all Vishal williiam
yes yesus Beth suar Hannah Ashok
Paar Joseph Naga Melinda
Wilson tlu Katlin wilred Natasha rufen
congratulations to
all before we move on to the next
program we would like to hear from a few
of our
graduates
today we have uh Marvin who would like
to share his experience with us can we
please move Marvin to the
panelist
I think Marvin hasn't joined with us uh
so we'll move on to the next uh
candate uh we also have your rajasri who
would like to share her experience with
us can we please move rajish to the
panelist yeah Rashi kindly request you
to switch on your camera as you
speak yeah so thank you Arun um so hello
everyone so first of all a big thank you
you to Simply learn and UMAS for the
thoughtful course content and learnings
that we provided you know via self-based
videos live virtual classes and Hands-On
projects as a learner I had a high
engagement learning experience with
realtime examples and applications to
master project management skills thank
you for helping us learn how to manage
you know complex large scale projects
while delivering results it was
interesting to know from expert
faculties on how how we can balance the
trade-off between cost risk you know and
quality while aligning with our
organizational goals so by acquiring the
skills in this core areas I'm confident
and I think that I'm well equipped for
exciting carrier opportunities ahead so
thank you once again I only wish that
the course duration was a bit longer
because we had to learn many things in a
fast baced environment that to very fast
and to quick so as a working it
professional with stringent deadlines I
had to juggle between my IT projects and
course projects I think if the course
duration was is a bit longer we can have
some time to do research in a better way
and even perform even better so but
overall I'm really glad that I was part
of this journey and I joined this course
I had U you know exciting uh time while
pursuing this because I learned so many
things in a short time and so I'm really
thankful for the Fantastic collaboration
that you know simply learn and UMass has
and also for the fa the collaboration
between faculties and the students and
last but not the least the support staff
they have been really really helpful
when we whenever I wished out to them
they were very quick in their responses
so thank you to the my the support staff
and my cohort in this journey so that's
all from my end thank
you thank you so much jri and we
definitely have taken the feedback that
you have shared regarding the course
duration we will take to the right team
thank you so much thank you yeah I would
also like to uh invite SAA who would
like to share his experience with us as
well can we please have SAA to the
panelist
hello uh I hope you can hear me now yes
sir I can hear you we all can hear you
okay so hello everyone U I'm swaba Muki
from Medford Massachusetts a Boston
neighbor uh serving as a principal
Analyst at palon Health not for-profit
healthc care services organization
headquartered in wer Mass I had the
opportunity to attend this pgp course
towards the end of last year I started I
think toward the end of the last year um
I would like to Echo what what Raji
mentioned yes this course was more than
just sticking to the book uh our
trainers filled the you know all the
lessons with real world examples and
important industry
knowledge and it was a real hands on
experience as in you know a lot of
courses a lot of things was jam-packed
and we know the fast pasted um
curriculum but then it was really
helpful to see how the case studies were
pertinent and relevant to the current
day world and not to mention we were
coming out of the
P so I think we lost
you uh Team can you check if someone
isn't there in the panel list still
yeah I think uh sorry for that it went
back to that being an
attende uh no worries uh yeah as I was
saying you know all the trainers they
were really great all the examples
especially I would like to thank you
know professors Alan Robinson and
Jeffrey Clark for sharing the Deep
industry knowledge and giv us a better
understanding of the field not to
mention of course it was very important
whenever we ran into any admin issues
their lessons were right there to help
us making sure we had a smooth and and a
supporting place to learn this was a
great blend of theoretical ACC human
reable skills and helpful learning you
know made this uh course a rich and
enjoyable Spirits thanks
everyone thank you so thank you for
sharing your experience and we are glad
to know that you know you had a
wonderful experience with us thank you
so
much the next set of graduates we have
is for the post-graduate program in
leanix Sigma the graduates
are Benson marjerie Shiva subramanyan
Arun Shanker Steve sures SRI suant
shanka CI lamach congratulations to all
Chang broing Cesar kolene Chan Derek
Diana knife Joi Samuel Alonso Carla
adrel ashwan Austin Aon Ammon batina
Benjamin branley congratulations to all
Dian
Dan obson and HRI Edna Emmanuel elah Isa
kba Florence fart Dominic nishat Russell
Crick Christa hael Howard hmon Jam Ahmed
congratulations to all Jenis Joseline
James Julie Fernandez Joshua M U Julio
Julie Keno C Kiran Crystal Karen Karthik
Matthew Lauren Lila garot Laura Jason
Ball congratulations
all rosan am Manmohan Lal Melinda Katlin
Mitch Misha
Mercy moit cheris mulah Mark kelwood
narina Kumar Justin
Nicholas Paul Paula Paul mono Ria
congratulations to
all Rahul Chand Donal Richard reat Ron
Albert Robert SRI wuki civi
Samuel D danila Samy SAS
subramanyan mus Sergio janin
shanmuga taol leis tagis shidan Thomas
Tiffany congratulations to all ugona um
Mahesh vun Victor Vin Vishnu Tara
William William Wendy worki Janine nson
pra congratulations to
all before we move on to the next
program we would like to hear from a few
of our graduates I would like to request
Benson to share a few words on his
experience with us can we please move
Benson to the panel
list Benson request you to switch oh
you're already there on the camp thank
you yes I'm right here okay I'm Benson
with 11 years of work work
experience I'm grateful for the
opportunity to be a part on the
convocation
ceremony congratulations to all the
graduates I'm glad with another
Milestone set on my career my sincere
thanks to all coaching
staffs coordinators who took their time
and given the guidance to skill
additionally I hooked up with
certification courses which was really
great I had an opportunity to connect
with people and agile
coaches it's been a great learning from
the agile coaches I would like to end
with a code it's a day to honor the past
and embrace the
future thank you and may we all reach
our determined success in our career
Journey thank you and good
luck thank you so much Benson for
sharing your
experience we also have umang who would
like to share his experience with us can
we please move uh umang to the panelist
as
well thank
you hello everyone uh myself om uh
recent graduate uh in Germany so I would
like to thank first of all simply learn
and UMAS M for the fruitful experience
uh throughout the journey and especially
I would like to mention the support team
from from the umast and the KPMG India
uh for their uh wide uh knowledge in the
field and giving us the realtime
projects that help to upscale
ourselves and the the the course was
very much fruitful and helped me uh very
much in advancing my career uh thank you
very much thank you so much umang and we
are happy that you had a wonderful
experience with us thank
you the next set of graduates we have is
for the postgraduate program in design
thinking and Innovation the graduates
are anelia Sund koteswar nadan Sudan
pradan congratulations to
all Kumar abishek Rohit Arn adash Sim
Swati Shaker congratulations to
all before we move on to the next
program we would like to hear from few
of our
graduates today we have Sudan L who
would like to share his experience with
us can we please move Sudan to the
panelist as well
Team all right sashan I think you have
the access to unmute yourself and turn
on the
cam uh hi hope you're able to see me now
I guess so uh I'm able to hear you but
uh the cam is not yet uh still
on yeah now I can see you yeah so I
would like to uh first of all thank for
giving me this opportunity to and uh
share my experience and I would like to
congratulate all the winners who have
being a part of this program and not
only this program for all the programs
we had a tough time in starting a course
but as the course passed by we were able
to learn few things and we were able to
apply things uh technically and uh like
apply in our day-to-day lives as well
and uh we had a good experience of
learning it theoretically but um it
would have been more better if we had
had more practical version but uh yes it
it indeed uh gave us a lot of
opportunity to learn more and more
things and uh uh like um apply things
and work on the same yeah I would like
to thank uh for giving me this
opportunity as well as uh thank everyone
for giving this thank you thank you so
much Sudan for sharing it with
us we had aumar but unfortunately I
think he hasn't joined uh the meet so
let's proceed
further
we are fully aware that each and every
one of you is an achiever as this
journey has not been an easy one however
we would like to acknowledge a select
group of Learners who have gone above
and beyond showcasing their competitive
spirit in light of this we have
organized two sets of awards for the
special
occasion the first category of awards is
a scholar award this award recognizes
the top two performers based on their
outstanding performance in comp
completing life classes projects and
assessments with the highest cumulative
scores first I would like to call out
the scholars of postgraduate program in
project management we have Kevin nyer
who has scored 90 marks followed by
Sunita who has scored 88.8 marks
congratulations to both of you before we
proceed I think I definitely want to
hear from Sunita to share her experience
uh with us can we please move Sunita to
the the panelist
team I think Sunita is also
unfortunately not there with us in the
meeting Sunita could you please uh
accept the panelist
access
all right I think we can proceed forther
coil and then come back to Sun later on
thank
you hey congratulations to both of
you the next set of scholar awards for
the program postgraduate program in
lean6 Sigma we have carolene who has
scored 90 marks followed by Melinda who
has scored 89.8 five marks
congratulations to both of
you the next set of scholar awards for
the program postgraduate program in
design thinking and Innovation goes to
abishek pava who has scored 83.1 marks
followed by pradan who has scored 82.8
marks congratulations to both of
you before we move on to the next set of
our I think we would like to hear from
pradan can we please move pradan to the
panelist
team thank you pradan the access has
been given to
you audible yes you're audible so I team
and thanks for recognizing this and I'll
also take honor to share my experience
it has been a great uh Journey so far
and let it be the learnings uh let it be
the faculties and also uh the content
that was moderated it was not too less
too long so it was right on spot and the
case studies the live uh scenarios that
we were given uh to practice with hands
on and also uh in uh each and every
module end of the module we were given
some projects to uh get grounds on work
and which really helped us to understand
the concept so I would like to thank uh
simply learn and new M the fact
faculties and a lot more people like Let
It Be customer service it has been a
great journey so far and I uh thanks to
all the people from bottom of mar and
congratulations to the graduates and
other fellow peers who has been joining
in this meeting
today thank you so much pradan uh thank
you for sharing uh your experience with
us and we are glad that you had a
wonderful uh Journey with simply
learn once more congratulations to all
of our
Scholars our next category is a
speedrunner
award this award acknowledges the
Learners who have shown remarkable
efficiency by completing the program
from start to end in the shortest
duration
possible first I would like to call out
the speedrunners of post-graduate
program in project management we have
bavana Muti who has completed her
program in 1011 days followed by Fida
who has completed her program in 102
days
congratulations to both of
you the next set of speed Runners awards
from the program postgraduate program in
lean 6 Sigma goes to Wendy who has
completed the program in 101
days and we also have Cesar who has
completed the program in 103
days congratulations to both of you the
next set of speedrunner awards from the
program design thinking and innovation
we have sundra quotes nadarajan who has
completed the program in 96 days
followed by Rohit deir who has also
completed his programs in 96 days
congratulations to both of you I would
like to invite uh sundra Adrain to share
his experience with us can we please
move uh s kesar to the panel
list
s quotation I think you have the access
I think you can unmute and turn on your
cam yeah I think uh can you see my
video uh not yet but I'm able to hear
you clearly
okay one sec let
me I hope you can see my
uh not
yet need to one second let me share my
screen can you see my screen
now uh no I think already presentation
is running we are unable to see the
screen I think I think we can proceed
yeah oh yeah I can see you now
yeah on so I want to thank simply learn
and also you my S for this program and
as you know the I come from a very
strict uh tight schedule while working
and then doing this course for uh doing
this postgraduation program so people
like me who are working uh with a very
tight schedule in the work and work and
then doing this course the weekend the
uh three points or bullet points which I
want to say first point is that the
course content that was given to us was
so so well prepared and it was so well
executed by the professors who were
teaching us uh that is one very
important we can't bring everything on
one platform but whatever they could do
to the best and then they they were able
to EXT we were able to EXT the content
from where we where the course was
taught to us that is first point second
point is uh the simply learn team that
is the whenever we post our sessions
each after each and session whenever we
post a particular comment on one
particular session they take it so
seriously on the platform and then
immediately they react the next session
and then it was so well coordinated by
simply learn team and with the
professors and the participants with us
the students it was well I should
appreciate that that is very important
factor so because of that I was able to
finish very fast with the team and able
to interaction was very fast third most
important point is that the course is
something like which has elevated me
from my job from the I was working
professional and now become an
entrepreneur with the Innovation so
things are changed this program has
changed drastically in terms of my
career as well so I would suggest I want
to thank the Lear team as as program for
choosing me as a speed render as well as
uh I want to thank whole simply Lear
team for executing this kind of work
because this is the first time I'm
coming for an online platform kind of
education and and I want I want to thank
everyone and then continue the same in
future thank
you thank you so
muchan thank you for sharing your
experience with us and we happy that you
had a good journey with simply learn
congratulations to all speed Runners
your speed is attributed to the time you
all allocated to your work you
prioritize this program and it really
shows in the ceremony we do acknowledge
your hard work and a digital badge will
be provided to all winners
congratulations
again now I would like to introduce to
you the team behind the scenes the team
has worked relentlessly to make sure you
have the best learning experience now
this is for you to put a face to the
names you may have heard and interacted
within the past
year I would like to start with our
Lifeclass
instructors they have been the major
pillars for your experience and I would
like to thank each one of them on your
behalf Aisha Lea Nar nagaraja rajendra
sandip Anita sain goswami sria shasi and
adir matur thank you
team we have few of our instructors who
would also like to uh share their
experience in training you all so I
would like to invite sain goswami to the
panelist uh to to speak a few words uh
to for our
graduates uh you you read me yes I can
hear you and I can see you as well all
right thank you so much uh first and
foremost for giving me this opportunity
and uh this is for all the participants
who joined this class and uh a lot of
these participants know me may know me
because of the classes uh but yeah so
we've been speaking right so all all of
us the instructors uh for many hours
right so I spoke for about 40 hours with
these participants now this is their day
so we need to acknowledge the hard work
and the effort so I want you guys to
just take a deep breath you know and
just pat yourself on the back because
you you deserve that and I'll tell you
why I'm saying this because with all the
work that you do you you all are most of
you are working professionals right and
in in that professional life to take out
the time attend a course you know and
successfully completing the course is is
something that should be should be
appreciated so today you know you always
appreciated the trainers for the
wonderful classes that they conducted
for you today we all wish to thank you
and congratulate you for being you know
dedicated uh show courage take a step
forward and you know I I also wish that
tomorrow many of you will go and you
know maybe appear in the PMP
certifications and the other
certifications and go and serve the
industry and as someday maybe one of you
you know uh would would be at a stage at
a platform where you can go back and
help others in achieving the same
success that that you have achieved so
all the best to all of you and uh thank
you so much for giving me this
opportunity to interact with you to
train you to discuss things with you and
I feel really humble and blessed that I
was a part of your journey thank you and
all the best for the future thank
you thank you so much sain thank you for
that motivational uh
Speech okay next we have uh the
instructor from uh postgraduate program
in lean Sigma we have Anita Stalin would
also like to share her experience in
training you all can we please have an
to the panelist oh yeah I can see hello
everyone first of all congratulations
to all the winners and congratulations
to all those who have graduated so thank
you I'm so happy I'm immensely happy so
congratulations to each one of you and
also the team behind the scene our uh
learner success management and admin
team and Arun I must say you're doing a
great job and and as well so thank you
so much for hosting this so so well
thank you great yeah uh so all my uh
lean Sigma students and also other
students you guys yes many many
congratulations to everybody like Madu
we have madua as well here great um yeah
so with all these
certifications um you know it shouldn't
be like just a paper in our file or you
know something that we already um we
would already have so many cert
certificates you know on an email and we
must have even forgotten that I we have
some certificate like this but um all
these that UMAS and simply Lear is
providing is not like a course but it
should be a way of life like like lean6
Sigma is not statistics and all you know
everything about numbers it should be a
way of life and how we think we should
think Lan isn't it now you see that
everybody is talking about
sustainability whether it is robotics or
it is lean6 Sigma it is digital
sustainability so which means that uh we
need to use the resources and also keep
the resources is for the um generations
to come isn't it so lean is also way of
life and I know each one of you who was
there in the class knows how to use it
and simply learn has designed uh the
last black belt such a way that we use
it practically because the last batch
did tell us that we wanted it to be more
practical we wanted to know how to use
it so I'm so sure that this team is
going to go out not only use that
certificate for your promotions and
increment and stuff but this is going to
be way of life for sustainability to be
to to make it a better Globe yeah so
thank you and uh sain has definitely
Professor Sachin has taken 50% of what I
wanted to say like you know thanking you
people uh for sparing time during the
weekends coming here and spending your
time with us because while while
training or teaching the trainers also
learn so much from the examples that you
give us so thank you so much Professor
Sachin and also Professor adir for
sharing the stage here okay
congratulations thank you thank you
thank you so much
Anita uh we also have uh the instructor
from design thinking and Innovation Mr
adir matur I kindly request adir mat to
be the panel list
yeah yeah thank you so much uh Arun and
good morning and good evening to every
one of you whichever time zone that you
are joining us from and thank you simply
learn for giving me this opportunity to
speak to all of you at the outset I'd
like to hearly congratulate each and
every one of you for successfully
completing the course the postgraduate
program of this stream that you have
done for right and uh this is also the
time to recognize and also acknowledge
appreciate and applaud the kind of
effort that has gone into the program
that you all have decided to do right it
also speaks about three things you know
the one number one is the kind of
commitment that you have shown to
yourself and number two is the
resilience and number three is the
tenacity right so the commitment because
you have decided to invest the time on
your own self you know taking out time
in the weekends maybe stretching
yourself right and it also calls for
resiliency because you have uh taken up
this challenge to invest time in your
own self at this part of your career
right and also the tenacity because you
have stretched yourself to go through
those classes and also go through those
assessments the Capstone projects that
you all have gone through right really
appreciate that and uh in every patch of
M I have also seen that there were
Learners from not only across the India
but also from different parts of the
world right so it brings a lot of
diversity into every batch it means that
there was a lot of experience sharing
and there were a lot of infractions
which were happening in every batch uh
which uh makes our learning all the more
richer right and at this point of time
I'd like to also thank the program
managers and also the backend team the
learning success managers the T who have
supported us all through for the success
of every back
and uh at this point of time I'd like to
only acknowledge and appreciate uh the
kind of efforts that has gone into the
program by each and every one of you and
I only wish that uh the knowledge that
you all have acquired right this is down
now the time has come for you to put it
into practice in the roles that you are
all in and take your career uh forward
right so wishing each and every one of
you a great career ahead and uh I come
from the subject of design thinking and
Innovation so I can only say that this
is the time for every one of us to
innovate and Propel our carriers forward
thank you so much back again to
youron thank you so much Adu thank you
for sharing
that let's now move on to the simply
learn team that provided endless support
throughout your
journey these individuals were
responsible for moderating all sessions
and the support requests you have
raised many of you may have interacted
with them directly or indirectly a huge
thanks to this team thank you
team the next team I would like to thank
is the instructor and Alignment team
responsible for providing us with the
best
instructors thank you
team now let's thank the product team
this team is a brains behind curating
the program and structuring
it thank you all
now to the now to the team responsible
for all the content and curriculum that
we see in terms of live virtual classes
labs and self-learning videos a huge
thanks to you
all and last but not least let's thank
our leadership team who regulates the
direction of all programs and oversees
the learner success team a big thanks to
you
all let's take a moment to once again
thank all the all teams and upload them
for their continued efforts thank you
all I also want to thank all of you who
have actively reviewed us on various
social media platforms we are incredibly
happy and excited to have received your
feedback and appreciation your feedback
has made us work harder fix a lot of
things and move forward to giving you
and your successors a better learning
experience to stay connected and receive
updates I encourage you to follow us on
our social media handles I hope you all
keep in
touch and
now we have come to the end of our
online convocation
ceremony we wish each and every one of
you the very best in your future
endeavors we believe that being
aspirational is the first step to being
successful you came here with an
aspiration and dream and we hope you are
now confident that you hold the
knowledge and experience to follow
follow through with that dream we are
honored and grateful that you plac your
trust in UMAS and simply learn we
express our gratitude to all of you for
joining us today and for contributing to
the success of this momentous event your
presence and active participation have
made it truly special as we bid you
farewell we wish you all a good night a
good day and good luck in all your
future endeavors thank you everyone for
joining today